يعني انا الان اقف تماما في النقطه
الحدوديه بين همم اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا على
بعد 400 متر فقط في هذا الاتجاه همم
الاراضي البيلاروسيه طبعا يمنع طبعا توجها
الكاميرا في هذا الاتجاه ولكن هنا طبعا
توجد تعزيزات كبيره جدا للجيش الاوكراني
في هذه الحدود ايضا اخبرني الضابط هنا في
الموقع المسؤول قال ان جميع الحدود هي
ملغمه بالالغام كذلك يوجد نقاط
لعمليات تمشيط في وكان على المسطحات
المائيه وطبعا هنا يوجد نهر النيبر الذي
يفصل ايضا بين دوله اوكرانيا ودوله في
روسيا كذلك بعد انتهاء منطقه المسطحات
المائيه بعد ذلك هنالك حدود حوالي 1000
همم كلمتر تفصل بين البلدين ايضا يوجد
نقاط مركز ايضا قاموا كما قال لي بقطع
الاشجار في الغابات التي تفصل بين البلدين
في المناطق التي يتمركز تتمركز فيها
القوات
للرؤيه وهم يراقبون على مدار الساعه
تحركات القوات البلا الروسيه والروسيه في
تلك المنطقه وقال اننا نستطيع ان نراهم
بالعين المجرده ونرسم تحركاتهم وايضا نقوم
بمراقبه الاجواء لاغلاق الحدود بشكل كامل
حتى الان همم هم مطمئنون على ان الحدود لا
توجد اي خروقات لا توجد اي عمليات تسلل من
قبل القوات وكان الروسيه او حتى
للمدنيين لم ترسل اي عمليات تسلل وقال ان
حتى الان هنالك احكام سيطره كامله على
الحدود ولكنهم جاهزونا لجميع
السيناريوهاتها يتوقعون طبعا هذا الحديث
ايضا افادت به كيف افاده به الرئيس الاسكي
رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه مدرب قال انه
هنالك
قد تكون امكانيه لزحف جديد من داخل
الاراضي الروسيه نحو وكيف طبعا هذه الحدود
هي الاقرب الى كيف حوالي ثلاث ساعات من
هنا من هذه النقطه همم الى العاصمه كيف
كذلك هنالك سيناري اخر طبعا ان تدخل
القوات
الاتجاه نحو الولايات الغربيه والسيطره
ومنع وصول الامدادات من الغرب همم من
الدول الغربيه من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبعد ذلك الوصول
طبعا الى الشرق الى جبهات الشرق هذا هو
الواضح حتى الان رايت ايضا بعيني وانا
وانا في طريقي الى هنا ورايت كيف تقوم
القوات بعمليه تلغيم للجسور والطرق وزرعه
الغابات يعني هذا امر وشاهدناه هو نحن
نعم اتحدث عن القوات الاوكرانيه التي
مازالت تواصل عمليه زرع الالغام حتى ان
الجنود قالوا لنا التحرك في اي مكان لم
يتم السماح به او لم يتم اخبارنا بامكانيه
التحرك فيه سيكون خطيره جدا لذلك
الالعاب المنتشرها قبل ان ينتهي وقتنا عن
تصريحات بوتن الاخيره عن انهم لن يتنازلون
عن الاراضي المنضمه الى روسيا في اي
مفاوضات قادمه هل من ردود فعل رصدتها داخل
اوكرانيا حول هذه التصريحات الاخيره
صحيح طبعا هذا الامر مرفوض تماما من قبل
السلطات الاوكرانيه ابتداء من الرئيس
بلادي ميرسي وجميع ال ال ال المسؤولين في
مكتب الرئيس كذلك في برلمان الشعب
الاوكراني تحدث
واعلق عدد من البرلمانيين حول هذا الامر
ايضا رصدنا نفط واسع من المواطنين اسمه
كان على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي او
بالحديث المباشر اليهم يرفضون ان يكون
هنالك اي تنازلات همم او اي مفاوضات
تتنازل عن الاراضي التي همم نتحدث عنها
وهي المناطق الاربعه طبعا دروس
ويقولوا مع انه سوف يقاتلون حتى الوصول
الى الحدود المعترف بها همم دوليا وهذا
الامر همم في الوقت الحالي طبعا هو مرفوض
من قبل الجانب الاوكراني وهو ليس من ضمن
همم
الرؤى التي تضعها كييف لي الحلم